the greatest movie of all time
a question no one ever asks me the room
my favorite movie of all time
it's the broom by the man the myth the
legend tell me why so I can watch this
movie infinite amount of times I never
get tired of it because every time you
watch it you find more [ __ ] that's wrong
with it I mean you find you find more
Easter eggs I want this video to just
convert you to go and watch this film
I'm gonna link it down below we don't
need another goddamn superhero movie
[Music]
Tommy charlie weis Oh so why is this
movie so great well let's start off with
just a snippet of one of my favorite
scenes just so you get a taste of the
movie yeah can I have a dozen red roses
please oh hi Johnny I didn't know what
you hear you go that's me
how much is it it'll be $18 go keep the
change
hi doggie you're my favorite customer I
feel it feels like watching marina Joyce
in the weird way like it's trying to get
as much information in there as possible
oh hi I didn't see what's you oh hi
Johnny oh you're my favorite customer
oh hi doggie but it's beautiful it's
spirits its art its art hi doggie you're
my favorite customer apparently he
didn't see the dog until they shot it so
he just all the sudden added in hi doc
you're my favorite customer there are so
many quotes from this movie that you can
apply to real life so if you watch this
film I think a lot of my videos will all
of a sudden just make sense the room
features drama I am going to call the
police mom stop it was Danny's mistake
just stop friendship
Johnny's my best friend love action how
can you be sure come on Lisa just stop
asking me stupid questions the hell do
you think you are
and love
[Music]
and some more love and even more love
maybe maybe too many love scenes okay
maybe just a tiny bit too many the film
was made by genius filmmaker Tommy
Wiseau and you will know this if you
watch the movie because it's mentioned
I'd tell me why so Charlie was Oh
[Music]
charlie
you
Charlie what is Oh tell me why its own
chattel me wet itself
Charlie wet itself
I've a chat me wet so now the story
features Tommy who plays Johnny hi babe
he's girlfriend Lisa I have something
for you
what is it and may I say it Lisa it's a
smoking hot you look beautiful today can
I kiss you everyone every male character
in the movie complements Lisa's
appearance at some point in the film
isn't it fabulous I would do anything
for my girl oh hey guys oh hi there the
acting the delivery the passion that
comes out of tommy wiseau spy and behind
them the movie also features one of my
favorite character oh hey guys Danny can
I kiss you Johnny and Lisa decides to
take and take a nap
nice to see you Danny I'm going to
digging up I think we both know where
this is going but for some reason that
Danny there's nothing weird about this
scene trust me we're just getting
started
Danny do you have something else to do I
just like to watch you guys Oh Danny
must be some kind of spawn from Satan
anyway we're five minutes in and it's
about to get smoked in let's turn up the
volume
kiss the soundtrack it's the best
yes Ainsley
[Music]
you know whenever me and might say yeah
you know put on this song
[Music]
I was through the forest
things look a happy there I have to go
now okay but just like an on and off
switch emotions can change and lease is
a testimony to that hi I don't love
Joanie huh how how did that happen what
happened between now and then okay this
doesn't hello hey baby how you doing oh
hey are you doing yeah I'm very busy
what's going on now Greg gets introduced
Greg of course wishes Johnny's best
friend I'm not gonna put up with that
I'm gonna do what I want to do and
that's it what do you think I should do
hey Ainsley
I want to do what I want to do and
that's it anyway what do you think I
should do no Greg now know you love
Johnny you're his best friend
no as much as it hurts this music makes
up for it
[Music]
Shh now afterwards there's a there's a
line from Greg that I always loved why
did you do this to me you had nothing to
do with with it Greg right they I mean
you're completely innocent right thanks
honey the beautiful you may think Tommy
just looks asleep during all the scenes
but don't worry about it that's a method
acting that makes it makes you drawn to
his character more a lot of people don't
know how to do it and that's definitely
real fruit by the way you're right the
computer business is too competitive oh
I love these lines so much because
they're just thrown out there the
computer business is too competitive
what does that mean
what does that mean to anyone does she
work in the computer business what is
that it's never brought up once again in
the movie but I always appreciate that
it's there it's a lot of open doors in
this room alright so they have a drink
they have some fun and we're about 20
minutes in for sexy number three yeah
the music it never stops getting good
[Music]
crave see so Lisa's mom is giving her
advice throughout what to do with this
situation she doesn't love Johnny
anymore and she needs she needs some
advice everything goes wrong at once
nobody wants to help me and I'm dying
you're not dying mom I got the results
of the tests back I definitely have
breast cancer so she the mom just drops
out of nowhere that she has breast
cancer and it's never brought up anytime
else in the movie it's just there she
has the breast cancer you may think this
is just random and stupid but no Tommy
Wiseau has deeper meaning and deep
thoughts into it all right it's to say
sathya it's a movie about many dark and
twisted themes like cancer now in comes
these two [ __ ] characters and we have
no idea who the [ __ ] they are but there
are in someone else's house and I know
where you're thinking oh god oh god
Felix another sexy it's getting there
it's definitely getting there we don't
get a sex scene though however we get
the weirdest ghost [ __ ] I have ever
seen
[Music]
this is arguably one of the greatest
scenes of the film however it's very
long and I don't I don't want to show
too much I want you guys to watch the
movie yourself let's just watch a tiny
snippet of it okay Danny Chris are I've
been looking for you
this guy is the only person in the movie
that is not an actor and I do think he
is the best actor in the movie what do
you mean it's coming penny where's my
money
however there's one scene that is
probably the best one in the movie it
lasts for seven seconds and it's the
best seven seconds of your goddamn life
I did not hit her it's not true it's
[ __ ] I did not hit her
I did not oh hi mark oh hi mark
apparently Tom Tommy was having a bit of
a rough day when shooting this and it's
it took a couple hours to get these
seven seconds I'm not I'm not kidding it
it took hours I did not hit her it's not
true it's [ __ ] I did not hit her I
did not
Tommy was struggling to remember the
lines which is not his fault probably
there were people on the set that
distracted him oh hi mark it took that
many hours to get that scene it's
because other people are unprofessional
I want you off the [ __ ] set you prick
now don't just be sorry think for one
[ __ ] second everyone just got so
tired after awhile that Greg just gave
him a water bottle and he said just
throw the water bottle that'll help you
get the line and they finally get the
shot and it's magnificent I did not hit
her it's not true it's [ __ ] I did
not hit her
I did not oh hi mark
so you can love someone deep inside your
heart and there is nothing wrong with it
if a lot of people love each other the
world would be a better place to live
art movie so Weiss I've learned half of
the decision I make in my life I always
reference the room and I I just go from
there it's a house Johnny I love this
scene because the continuity is a little
flawed I think what really happened here
was a glitch in the matrix and the
glasses are just teleporting and it's
nothing to do with Tommy Wiseau he
didn't get his promotion is he
disappointed quite a bit oh now it's in
her hair drunk last night she's drinking
now was she's picking it up and he hit
me he hit you you didn't know what it
was doing
now she's drinking I know she's drinking
again well I don't want to marry him
anymore
yeah she's deaf she's pretty good away
the next time to skip the glasses sexy
number four is
there's four here's the thing of what I
love about the room compared to other
movies that are supposed to be so bad
that they are good the room is still
somewhat coherent I mean that and it has
atmosphere it has it has something
special now there's so much more that I
can point out and I love this movie so
much but I want you to enjoy it as well
so I highly recommend that you watch it
I'll link to Tommy's website and to
where you can buy the film and watch it
yourself I highly recommend it the
reason why I love the movie so much the
movie and how and why it was made is
equally interesting Tommy Wiseau is such
an interesting character and the reason
why he wanted to make this movie is it's
a movie on itself it's a story on its
own knowing all the context for watching
the film it makes it even better
if you're intrigued by this video I
highly recommend that you check it out
the computer business is very
competitive so I'm gonna have to end
this video now but please do leave a
like and check out this video right here
and I'll see you next time